13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hi I'm Tracy and today's video workout
really excited to bring you I have a
special guest
you guys know Joanna I need to tell you
that this was Joanna's very first time
doing the booty burn workout so that
means that if you're a beginner you'll
be able to do this
yeah beginners do not be intimidated
yeah this is my first time ever ever
ever
why do you what to do what you do need
to get is a booty band and they're
really accessible from any exercise
store and you could probably even get it
at a toy shop okay so make sure that
when you do get a booty band it's not
too tight so you want to be able to
stretch it with your arms like this and
that'll be a good place to start from
if you continue this workout then and
you feel that it's not getting any
harder
feel free to upgrade to a tighter booty
band today's workout is about 30 minutes
long it's a total body conditioning
workout you're going to see about 15
different exercises that you can use the
band for to help to tone and strengthen
your body there's also some cardio in
there see you ready for that I am okay
so let's get straight to it
[Music]
[Music]
first things first one of the most
important exercises that we do with the
booty band is a squat so let's have a
quick recap on how to squat pop the
booty band around your ankles and keep
it down quite close to your shoes cool
all right we are game on take the feet
wider than the hip and just a warm up
squat you're going to set your hips
straight back try to keep your chest up
and come back up again and you do
whatever you like with your arms okay so
there's a big focus on your lower body
for the first part okay so we're off so
sit your hips back have a look as I step
back I'm keeping my chest high keeping
my eyes on the horizon as you start to
warm up maybe go a little bit faster
it's up to you it's we're kind of moving
in sync here because that's what happens
when you get two girls doing a booty
band workout awesome so you start to
warm up your legs press your knees out
keep your quads and your glutes really
engaged when you come up squeeze your
booty yeah you want to start from the
get-go make a difference right from the
beginning
all right just ten more seconds and then
we're going to take a ten second break
to preview the next move all right five
more seconds starting to get warmer in
the legs and one all right the next one
is squat whole pulse so you're gonna
take the squat that you're gonna stay
here you can do whatever you like with
your arms I recommend reaching them out
because it keeps your shoulders back and
we're just going to squat and hold yeah
like that so you might have done this
move without the boom Bend yep so we're
just gonna up the ante a little bit and
you start to feel a bit of pressure on
the legs okay so that band is adding the
extra pressure of intensity and
resistance
keep pushing a tailbone back make sure
your core is nice and strong back
through the shoulders good so that's
tiny little bounce starting to feel it
in the quads I put a heat there
you're so close 15 seconds to go
keep breathing and notice your heart
rate coming up good doing really well
five seconds
all right our next move we're actually
really gonna stay low but you can come
out get the legs a little bit of a
release how we doing
burning okay okay next move is called
the crab walk so come down maybe bring
your hands just here to keep them out of
the way we're gonna take two steps to
the right and two steps to the left and
we're gonna keep moving so back and back
to the other side you're trying to
stretch the band and when you step also
just push your toes slightly out to the
corners yeah so that's going to keep the
knees and line keep the knees safe okay
so there's a big focus here on working
the abductors your outer thighs yes
everyone loves this move
I've seen it in lots of exercise classes
I look I know lots of personal trainers
like to use this as well it's a great
warm-up move before leg day five seconds
I think we can keep going can we go that
lower yeah awesome come out of it
alright but a cardio the old jumping
jack so you're gonna just take the legs
wide land your heels and if you want to
use your arms on your Maps go alright so
we're gonna get the heart rate up here
push your knees out soften your heels to
the floor and keep your core nice and
strong
awesome starting to breathe you can hear
it
I like cardio so I try to bring a little
bit into every workout it gives you that
feel good and orphan high how those
jumping jacks with the bend
yeah that's good
you're doing really well keep going five
seconds three two one okay next one is
jumping jack with a double bounce we're
gonna stay low so we're gonna go out and
out and and off we go okay what's going
on here as you're getting very little
respite very little rest for the legs
okay check it out push the knees out
yeah that looks good
alright keep the chest up and stretch
that band you can thank us later beach
bikini booty 20 seconds
keep breathing if you need to slow down
you can and here's an option out out and
and I know you're thanking me right now
aren't you right
i thicken so close all right we have the
booty burp here
so check out I'll show you one version
so we're gonna sit back hands down
jump back with the feet wide jump back
in and finish here let's go just do as
many as you can
oh so when you come up push your knees
out keep the band tight good so there's
a bit of cardio core that's a spring
those legs back awesome
this is turning into quite the workout
this is my go-to when I go on holiday I
just pack that band and do a 20 minute
workout okay we're close five seconds
maybe two more reps maybe one more great
bring it out okay we are going to squat
and lift the left leg stay on the left
shall we do it let's go so squat and
lift squat and lift good when you come
up try to go up straight so you don't
want to be leaning to the side your leg
that lifts to the side make it straight
so really push up with that ankle good
drop right down and drive right up
pushing through the heel and then
squeeze about awesome all right what's
good for one side it's gonna be good for
the other right so start thinking about
it ten seconds okay this is just giving
us that we chance to catch our breath
but keep working through the leg all
right breathe give it a shake nothing
shaking now it's a perfect workout okay
three thicken we're going to the other
side let's go drop lift all right this
is the part where I start to think nice
thoughts feeling positive productive
thoughts to my gluts right in there
getting into your gluteus medius your
muscles that help you walk run and stay
and Vita 20 seconds to go
alright we've got enough and we're on
the home straight with the standing work
and the cardio work I bet you're
wondering what's coming up next this
that you don't know we'll just do it one
more okay we have another version of
Jack it looks like this three two one
and so progressively getting wider you
ready let's go three two one and so out
out wider slide it in that's it now
sometimes you just want to get rid of
those and so keep them nice and close
focus on the lower body yeah you're
getting it can you feel it she can feel
it you can thank me later
keep going just 20 more seconds we can
do this and then we're gonna go move
towards the upper body we have one big
move to bring our cardio booty bands to
the finish ten seconds
stay low come on stretch it one two
three
last one yeah bring it up and breathe
last exercise check this out we're gonna
sink back and do a little jump a little
jump your option come up on your toes
reach or and back cut it down and jump
squat back jump down left good alright
so this is pretty big pie metric work
here if you're starting to feel like
it's just a little too much bring it
down come up on your toes just do as
many reps as you can and come back to it
yeah you know that you're on the home
straight here weights go good brace your
belly
help oh and feel the legs fire it up
10 seconds come on Joanna yes 5 3 1 yes
okay all right we're doing really well
we're gonna take a little break we're
gonna bring the met into the workout if
you need to grab some water now's a good
time take your band with you oh okay
so we're gonna add some upper body we're
gonna start by standing and then we'll
come down to the floor okay so take the
band off your ankles pop it underneath
your left foot and make sure the band
goes directly underneath the shoe and
not out by the toe
okay so straight underneath where your
shoelaces would be it's to keep it safe
lift right left foot in front right foot
behind bring the other hand to your hip
we've got this movement here down
squeeze down and left let's go squeeze
good so you'll notice that back leg is a
little bent the front leg is slightly
bent because we're targeting your
hamstrings
okay so pull the elbow back squeeze into
the back of the shoulder go keep going
SoCo tip forward squeeze down lift up
straight lead with the chest when you
stand up and keep that spine really long
awesome so we are targeting hamstrings
back muscles still in the total body
exercise range 20 seconds to go all
right starting to also let the heart
rate come down a little bit I just
noticed I can breathe we want to keep
the reps high max out the rips through
one minute
awesome okay last one now hold it here
so we're gonna hold it here and we're
just going to pull and pull and squeeze
that set so squeeze in to the shoulder
blade that's it and if you release it so
if you get a little stretch underneath
your armpit as well get a little bit of
a let work out that's a toning and
strengthening your back muscles we don't
really look at our back so we don't
think of that very often
but we need to work it just as hard as
our front we need our upper body lower
body front body and back body to be as
even as possible so squeeze all right
doing really well it's starting to feel
a slight burn maybe in the back of the
shoulder the hats and your bicep all
good things keep breathing
getting the sweet on 10 seconds to go
and then we're gonna switch legs three
two one release all right good job
switch over so one leave behind dig that
toe into the floor hips nice and level
here we go down pull down and stand
that's it now one thing you want to try
not to do is try not to curve through
the back like this so when you took
forward tip with a straight spine until
you feel the stretch up the back of the
thigh your hamstring okay when you feel
that you know you've got it awesome
bring it up squeeze it in hello back
muscles
I'm wondering what work at Joanna's
gonna do tomorrow you're gonna feel this
one this is such a good workout for your
whole body and all it takes there's a
tiny little booty band last one okay
hold it down take a moment to breathe
and we're gonna kick into those single
rose on your max gets it and go for it
row the boat pull it away good squeeze
eyes forward
Nick long I'm strong if you're starting
to feel your front leg shaking a little
bit that's normal okay that's an
isometric contraction of your hamstring
so that's a good thing getting a bit of
a lower body back body workout squeeze
just 20 seconds ripping into it awesome
hang on tight squeeze squeeze ten
seconds to go maybe about five more reps
three two one and release shake it out
okay take the band above your head we're
going to take a single single and then a
double pull okay so we'll go left arm
right arm both lift up right arm both
arms now the key here is to actively
stretch the band right so it's not just
pulling the band here it's actually
pulling the band apart pulling it apart
okay so you're targeting into your back
muscles so check it out
left right pull left right pull into the
back good keep going
squeeze try to keep your shoulders away
from your ears so your neck is long and
bring those elbows down to your ribcage
yes getting stronger through your upper
body through your back muscles to one
last one awesome okay hands inside the
bean like this yeah and then bring your
elbows into your ribcage and you're just
going to do little pulses out to the
side like this working your doubtful
muscles your shoulder muscles yeah we're
talking Lara Croft shoulders right here
yes squeeze that's building some tension
for the shoulders you might even feel a
little bit have that happening through
the neck so feel free to just took the
head from one side to the other to
release it now try not to let the lower
body or the upper body move just the
arms slow it down if it gets too much
okay get good quality reps in there
squeeze and breathe
we both slowed it down it's like all
good things but up a burn bit of a booty
burn one more great come down onto your
mat okay so we want to keep our hands
inside the booty band just like we
finished the last one come down we have
tricep push-ups so bring your hands
under your shoulders knees away from you
and then bend the elbows back to the
ribcage good so the band around your
wrist is just giving you a little bit
more tension in the arms okay so take
your time here's an easier option bring
your knees closer Jonah's going to keep
going and then you can drop your elbows
towards the floor like this okay working
the triceps otherwise legs back head
towards the floor it's at one long line
through your body press your hands away
like push yourself away from the ground
keep going okay we're gonna get a rest
after this so we're doing a chest press
and then we're going to do another pull
so one push in one pour all right come
up onto your knees and grab the band and
we're going to do a row towards the
chest
so really actively squeezing into your
shoulder blades there we go so pull the
elbows back and then pull the band apart
alright so once again not slacking with
the band keeping it really tight okay
the band is tight and your muscles will
be too that's kind of how it works so
have a look your hips are directly over
your knees squeeze the elbows back so
they come back behind the body and
lengthen through the neck that's it and
all the way through all of these
exercises you're keeping your core
engaged so you can maximize great
technique really focusing on the muscles
that we want to work today it's the
whole body keep going
eight seconds that's it breathe home
straight we're gonna do one more round
of tricep pushup choose to touch the
blue the band if you want to otherwise
put it back around their wrists and head
towards the ground here we go good okay
so we're trying to do quality tricep
push-ups to target the back of the arms
yeah did you know that you could do
these things with the band for your
upper body right yeah it's a great
little workout if you're getting if you
feel like you're getting really strong
doing bodyweight exercises and you're
feeling really comfortable if you just
draw in a booty band you'll get extra
burn maybe extra results that's the game
that's the goal 15 seconds
that's good Joyner she's had her fair
share of tricep push-ups I can tell I
call them chaturanga lots coming up all
right
last exercise from the knees the delts
all right the burner
all right let's wait for it and hit okay
so trying to keep the elbows in at the
ribcage it's that pull the band apart
you'll be happy to know this is your
last upper body exercise great getting
some blood into those muscles all right
keep it coming
think of the results
the sweat we've got sweat keep going
ten more seconds you can do it you don't
need to speed it up just keep stretching
the band five seconds four three two one
all right that's it upper body okay
we're going back to the floor and we're
really going to start focusing on the
booty so we've got a couple of exercises
where we just do the booty okay
traditional booty band exercises you may
have seen them before and then we're
also gonna work some core and we're
gonna finish with some thrusters
okay what's the band all right so to be
safe and to do it really well
pop the band around the top of the shoe
so it's right across the shoelaces like
that okay it needs to be up quite high
so it doesn't come off your foot all
right now come over onto your hands and
knees you might want to face me to do
this one so shoulders directly over the
hands knees under the hips we're going
to start with the donkey kick so start
with your front leg and you're going to
kick it straight back behind you and
keeping the toe facing down so it looks
like that so straight back and not
lifting it higher than the hips alright
so we push back and bring the knee in
back and stay with that foot yeah so
push with the heel that's it and start
to feel a squeeze and your glutes and
you might feel it in your hamstring too
so we want to put a both now one thing
that starts to happen that you start to
sort of lean away from the leg try to
straighten up and keep the core strong
so when the lead goes straight back it
doesn't go higher than your hips point
the toe down keeps the gluts really
active well 20 seconds to go yeah this
is kind of like a build-up to the next
one
alright keep going push you got 10 more
seconds we're gonna take a quick
breather before we go into one of our
bigger moves for the booby we're gonna
hold the leg out and pulse it okay just
take a moment okay we need this moment
we're gonna straighten the leg straight
out and we're going to hold it here and
pulse up and down okay we have 50
seconds so let's go so little squeezes
up and down yeah that looks really good
that's it squeeze squeeze all right so
feeling the glute medius performace all
those deep gluteal muscles that help to
keep your hips tracking normally keep
your back nice and strong good so as you
do this one thing to note is whether you
start kind of swinging through the upper
body and lock it in here so that upper
body is really fixed just that leg is
moving we've got ten seconds home
straight five four three two one
bring it on rest okay now we have fire
hydrant okay so you're going to lift the
leg up to the hip and then back down
okay as many reps as you like but always
trying to keep the body still just let
the leg lift off we go now a really
amazing phenomena happens here as you
lift the leg away from your body the
opposite hip contracts you should start
to feel that and the opposite hip as
well can you feel that yeah that's the
crazy thing isn't it
so as we're working this side the
stabilizer muscles the other hip is also
working - for one more bang for your
buck 15 seconds
all right making a difference here five
seconds to go
and maybe one more rep awesome alright
we're gonna switch sides
maybe a little hip circle oh okay we're
ready
three two and push it away so in and out
that's it press it away and you're I
guess maybe to the top of your mat so
that will just keep your neck long as
well yeah we want to maintain the
integrity of your spine so we can just
focus on the muscles we want to work
push the heel away breathe squeeze into
the booty alright we're doing so well
you'll be happy to know you've probably
got about another six minutes of work
and you would have worked your whole
body specific focus on the lower body if
you're wondering how do you work your
core with this funky little piece of
apparatus coming up last one rest and
then we're gonna pulse you ready we've
got sweat here by the way all right
legs straight toes down BAM
game on alright little pulses good
squeeze
we could package up this little workout
and sell it with a bikini promising
results here 30 seconds alright if you
hear me go quiet it's usually for a
reason called and feel in this ah all
right
the second side for some reason has
massive empathy for the first side nine
seconds oh my goodness
three two one little wrist okay you
ready for that fire hydrant oh yeah
partner
alright let's cut it so look to the side
I'm just going to turn around here so
you guys can see how high that leg is
going so it's only coming out probably
just below the hip or four for you guys
if you're doing this for the first time
maybe you can bring it to here because
you're struggling with the resistance of
the bear met totally normal okay so as
you get stronger you'll be able to lift
the hip a little higher lift the leg a
little higher good see if we can get
another team Ritson going
ten more seconds might mean five more
it's oh wow three two more and one more
it's all right well done pop the band
around your ankles again and we're gonna
come into some core training we're gonna
do some plank work yes okay so on your
forearms take your feet behind the mat
because you're going to need the mat to
be out of the way come to a plank
and we're gonna go right foot out left
foot out right foot in left foot in so
we walk it out out in and out out and
and so even when we're doing our core
training here we are working our glutes
with the band so press your forearms
into the floor to support your upper
body and try not to roll the hips just
step the feet wide and step and back in
ten seconds to go you're doing great
come on all right coming up onto your
hands this time we're doing plank Jack
okay just one minute of point Jack all
right let's do it let's hit it think
about your breathing okay
remember your option I've already set up
the option you can go out out and and
Johanna is a gun at plank Jack so I'm
gonna leave you with that keep your hips
down that's it
otherwise pick it up again do what you
can do when you can do it
come on keep going
what walk it out come on nearly there
let's go let's go ten seconds by four
three two one
yes okay let's live feet to feet bring
the band over your knees we've got a hip
thrust up we've just got two more
exercises to go so doing so well
bringing the heels up nice and close to
the hips relax the upper body and when
you're ready feet apart
just lift the hips and drop it down lift
the hips drop it down so the movement is
simple press with your heels to get your
hips up as high as you can squeeze your
butt all right so we're targeting right
underneath the glutes
we're also strengthening your lower back
extensor muscles so that's going to help
support your posture as well squeeze the
gluts all right push up and now the band
around your legs is just adding a little
bit of extra tension so making a
difference okay this time hold it up
wait here we're gonna go abductors so
out and this is your last one minute hit
up make it count
here we go out and out and that's it
keep your hips high try not to let them
drop down and lose the effect push into
your hip your heel heels and out and
then just as many as you can so you
might be right up on your shoulders
that's all good squeeze squeeze
alright we're gonna pick up the pace now
we've got 25 seconds and we're done
all right thinking good thoughts ten
seconds left
yes yes we deserve cake and done take
that band off it piece of torture and
we're going to do some really good
stretchers to finish our workout today
how'd you guys go I usually throw it
away like that
yeah be God all right take one leg
across the ankle over the knee we're
gonna take the pretzel stretch it's
probably the most idyllic stretch for
this workout so reach behind the
hamstring drop the head back and see if
you can pull the legs a little closer ah
I'm free so we're gonna take about 20
seconds each stretch 30 seconds if you
want to go longer you go longer okay
just breathing into the hips
and then switch side so flex the foot
protect the knee reach behind the
hamstring and relax the head back oh yes
so you'll notice you might feel the
stretch a little bit more than you
normally would you've really worked your
glute muscles so many reps okay there's
a big emphasis on repetitions with the
booty band yes I'm just breathe
hug both knees into the chest and then
we're going to drop both knees over
towards the front towards us and then
reach back with the opposite arm so
releasing through the lower back because
ultimately when you do work your glutes
a lot and your quads a lot your lower
back does get very tight as well take a
deep breath in and exhale lift the knees
up and over and let's go to the other
side drop to the side and reach back see
if we can get that back shoulder on the
ground if you can't move ultimately we
want to stretch that lower back inside
of the hip
and just bring the knees up to you and
we're going to sit up cross the legs and
just reach forward to the top of your
mat and release through your lower back
and your hips close at the same time if
you got that mobility off you go a
little bit lower
and let's take one more stretch so
stretch you out one leg long and the
other leg over the top
second spine behind you sit up nice and
tall take a deep inhale plant there
elbow to the outside me and have a look
over your shoulder
add a little bit of traction with your
elbow and to the side of the leg and
change size and how breath lengthen the
spine exhale place it to the outside of
knee that's it as you feel the tension
just take a deep breath as you exhale
smile really helps with the relaxation
it's proven science yeah
and we're just going to finish with the
butterfly stretch so soles of the feet
together and let the knees fall down
towards the floor and sit up nice and
tall that's it bring your heels as close
or a far away from your groin is as
comfortable just so that you can stretch
through that inner thighs and relax
through the other thighs yes we did it
our first booty burn workout yeah it's a
good sweat and release so how did you
guys go all right first workout is
awesome anywhere anytime you can do it
at home you can do it at the beach you
can do it on holiday you can do it with
Joanna thing you do it with me
yeah my first booty bed ever
and I have to say it's a total burner
yeah really good workout I can feel my
lower body especially great workout
great workout for the lower body get to
it you're gonna try and don't forget to
check out other classes tomorrow with
other trainers as well yeah we'll see
you then